[MUSIC PLAYING]
QUENTIN HARDY: Many
businesses have
invested large amounts
of time and money
in on-premise security
policies and controls.
When you work with our open
ecosystem of technology
partners, you're able
to take your existing
controls into the Cloud
and mitigate threats
more effectively.
To discuss this further, I
have with me Vineet Bhan,
head of Security Technology
Partnerships at Google Cloud;
Adam Geller, vice president of
product management at Palo Alto
Networks; and Ming Chang, Cloud
Security Awareness lead at SAP.
Thanks fellas, for coming.
Vineet, why don't you talk a
little bit about Google Cloud's
philosophy when it comes
to partnering technology
partners and security?
VINEET BHAN: Sure.
Google's philosophy is to create
an open ecosystem of partners,
so we can meet customers where
they are in their journey
to migration in Cloud.
So customers would have a choice
of using Google technology
and combine them with best of
breed security partnerships.
So it will also help in Google
and partners working closer
together in the future to create
the next generation of security
products.
That will be a lot more
easier and automated than what
customers are used
to having today.
QUENTIN HARDY: OK, so an
easier journey in the future,
meet them where they
are, take them forward.
Adam, as one of the
partners in the ecosystem,
but also a strong leader
in security for many years,
talk a little bit about how
customers are viewing the Cloud
and how it might
have been changing
over the past couple of years.
ADAM GELLER: Sure.
So when a lot of our
customers started
making the Cloud
journey, to be honest,
security wasn't
their top priority.
Their major focus
was speed and time
to market for the applications
they were building,
and to a lesser extent,
possibility of maybe cost
savings for a different
method for deploying
their applications.
But those apps really
were focused, typically,
on development and
test workloads.
So the emphasis from
a security standpoint
was a little bit lower.
Fast forward to
where we are today,
and there's no
question that Cloud
is used for very
advanced production
workloads with high-quality
and very sensitive data.
So as you'd expect,
what's moved along
with that is the emphasis
on enterprise class
security and really bringing
along the concepts that
were critical in an enterprise
data center, making sure
those can still be
applied in the Cloud
but now apply them
in a different way
based on the capabilities
of the Cloud environment.
QUENTIN HARDY: Let
me stop you there
and talk a bit about what
the key concepts would be
and how they're reflected
in products or services
we're offering.
ADAM GELLER: Sure.
So fundamentally, if your
objective, as an organization,
is to prevent a
successful attack,
you need to think
about four things.
You need to be able to
have full visibility.
And we're talking mostly about
network security right now.
But this really applies broadly
across the security landscape
for an organization.
So it's four things.
It's complete visibility.
It's the capability to
reduce an attack surface area
to a meaningful scope of work.
It's to be able to successfully
prevent any known attack.
You should be able to
prevent it outright,
so you don't have
to think about it.
And then for things that
are truly unique and unknown
or novel-- they've
never been seen before--
you need to be able to detect
and prevent it very quickly
and turn that time around,
so that it becomes something
that you've known already
and then you can deal with.
QUENTIN HARDY: OK.
And so those four areas
travel with the customer,
those concepts, those practices
travel with the customer
into the Cloud.
How do things change, the
number of touch points,
the level of compute?
And how do you speak to that
in the products and services
you're offering?
ADAM GELLER: Sure.
So when we work with
Google Cloud Platform,
it's the application of
those four principles.
They change, because the
environment necessarily
is different than what
the enterprise controls,
themselves, in their
traditional data center.
So in Google, we
have the opportunity
to integrate in from a
networking standpoint
differently, from the
context-sharing information
that we learn that we can
share with the Cloud Platform,
and what the Cloud
Platform can share with us.
That all adds up to a much more
automated and scalable solution
that looks very
different operationally
from what people have
done traditionally
in their data centers.
QUENTIN HARDY: Now Ming, let
me turn to you because SAP has
relationships going back years--
and in some case, decades--
with thousands of
companies around the world,
really reshaping
the way things are
manufactured, finance,
distribution of goods,
all sorts of things.
How are the customers
viewing security
in the Cloud and the
move to the Cloud,
particularly since we've
started this deep relationship
with Google in the past year?
MING CHANG: Security is
definitely top of the concern,
but also how to manage
the security risks,
as well as meet the
regulatory requirements.
And to be in a competitive
market to succeed,
customer has the choice
to move to Cloud,
which is the best
choice that they have
about the scalability,
the flexibility,
as well as the cost and the
security embedded to it.
QUENTIN HARDY: What
is the priority
they have where
security is concerned,
protection of data,
threat vector,
changing contexts
or styles of work?
What do you see?
MING CHANG: Sure.
Definitely the security,
the application security.
The platform that runs
needs to be secure.
The visibility that
they need to have
to manage their
security, as well as,
how are they going to meet
the regulatory requirements?
They need to provide reports,
requirements of visibility
to whoever they
need to respond to.
QUENTIN HARDY: I
want to ask you all
a little bit about the future.
And I'll start with you, Ming.
Where do you see the
partnership going,
in terms of what SAP wants
to deliver to its customers?
MING CHANG: Sure.
The partnership is great.
SAP and Google are able
to create a data custodian
solution, which can provide
the customer ability to set up
the controls that they need,
as well as the visibility.
With the Google's
highly-secure public Cloud
and SAP's knowledge
and experience
on managing the
business processes,
we can make the customers
exceed when they are
in the competitive environment.
QUENTIN HARDY: Adam?
ADAM GELLER: So where I see this
going is an evolution from sort
of the basic integrations
and basic starting point of,
how do I do something similar
to what I had in my enterprise
data center, to how I'd do it
much more natively and much
more integrated
in with the fabric
that Google Cloud
Platform is providing?
And that, typically, will hit in
areas of automation and scale,
again.
And it's automation from
the deployment standpoint
and infrastructure,
but also, then,
the automation on how I process
and respond to actual security
events and alerts.
QUENTIN HARDY: And
Vineet, where do you
see partnership going
inside Google Cloud?
VINEET BHAN: So our
vision is to work along
with best of breed partners,
like SAP in Palo Alto,
and make security as a driver
for migration to the Cloud.
So as companies are evaluating
the migration to the Cloud,
they can see security
[INAUDIBLE] in the Cloud
that Google has developed
with their own technology,
combined with best
of breed partners.
It's so much better
than what they could get
in an on-premise deployment.
QUENTIN HARDY: Very helpful.
Gentlemen, thank you very much.
VINEET BHAN: Thank you.
ADAM GELLER: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]